welcome everybody next week the United
Nations climate action summit will take
place in New York City CBS News has
joined several news organizations
worldwide in a project that we are
loving it's called covering climate now
now we're continuing our coverage right
now in the toyota green room with
climate scientist Peter Domenico he's
the Dean of science at Columbia
University lamont-doherty he's with us
to talk about how we can all help the
planet and we're also gonna be talking
about you know all the kind of crazy
things that we're seeing one of those
which i think is most interesting is the
fact that we have this you know
incredible prolific rain producing
tropical system were now remnant
tropical low across Texas it was imelda
but it somehow managed to dump 43 inches
of rain in a very short period of time
so I think the the question is and of
course Harvey we had in 2017 produced up
to 60 inches of rain in parts of Texas
and there been a couple of other notable
big you know one in 100 or one in 1,000
rain events one of them thousand-year
reign events although on the Gulf Coast
including including Louisiana a couple
years ago so the question is what is or
is there a climate change component to
this right so the questions often
pitched as you know is this particular
storm do do global warming and that's
really not the question we like to ask
the question is was this storm made more
destructive because of something that's
associated with global warming and
indeed that's true with really many of
the hurricanes that we've seen over the
last decade or so the reason is that the
oceans are warming and as the oceans are
warming that's where we're getting all
the energy that feeds the Hurricanes
that's what feeds the moisture and the
Hurricanes so this these tropical
depressions that rapidly intensify and
that's sort of a word in the field they
turn from a tropical depression to a
hurricane or tropical storm very quickly
overnight these things are just juiced
up with water vapor and so when they
come on land and they stall they dump
three feet of water alright you know
there have been a lot of studies on
hurricane Harvey and how much extra rain
was caused because of climate change and
those numbers range from the teens
somewhere in the teens maybe 15% more I
saw one study that said it could have
been as much as 38 percent more Kerry
Emanuel from M
T said that it was biblical in that it
was a one in nine thousand year possible
possibly flood looking at some of the
stats in that paper earlier today you
know rainfall of 35 40 inches tends to
be a 1000 year flood which puts this
particular situation at but one in a
thousand year mark but you know so
essentially a 1% chance would be one in
a hundred so a 1,000 year storm would be
a tenth of a percent chance in any given
year but we've had to in a matter of
like right two years or so so what do
you say to that so this is actually one
of the you know the fingerprints of
climate change is that we start seeing
these very low probability events
becoming more frequent far more frequent
than you expect in what we call the
tails of the distribution so if this is
the average of all events and then you
have these kind of rare really extreme
events there's supposed to be rare and
extreme and what we're seeing is we're
getting several of those per year and
what's surprising about it is that or
what's why it matters is because this is
directly impacting people I mean this is
this is where people live their losing
their homes their getting this really
tremendous flooding in a really rapid
period of time you know I'll transition
to Dorian because Dorian is also top of
mind immense straw dinelli scary the
United States is extremely lucky Florida
in particular that the storm veered off
and and moved north what kind of
elements of climate change is involved
with these bigger stronger stronger
systems right so one of the things
that's been going on in the climate
community most recently is that these
are really following textbook physics
for people who are following or not
physicists it's that one of the things
that we're seeing with the changing plan
is that the oceans are warming so that's
providing more energy so the storms are
getting stronger they're holding more
water therefore more rainfall they're
getting larger but then when they come
on land they stall alright and this is
what's causing the damage so this is
what happened with Dorian this is what
happened with the storm this week and
this is what's happened with with Harvey
so what's been happening is that they
they get juiced up with with the warming
energy of the of the oceans taking lots
of rainfall they come in like
gangbusters on for the coast and then
they
all and that's what causes you know the
immense damage that we've seen in all
three of these examples and the reason
for the stalling we believe is that the
the Jetstream is weakening a little bit
and so there's the the tendency for the
Jetstream to kind of push away the
hurricane and send it back out to the
Atlantic which is what normally happens
that's not happening as much now they're
stalling and that stalling is what's
calling it causing the damage so it's
essentially a more moisture that's being
held because of warmer warmer air
stronger storms because because the
ocean is warmer plus also probably
feeding into deeper convection thus the
rain rates are even higher so it's not
just a matter of the atmosphere holding
more moisture but it's actually the
convergence of that moisture being
greater increasing the rain then
stalling likely because of in some way
climate change I know James Carson's
research shows that Atlantic hurricanes
are stalling or slowing down by about
sixteen or seventeen percent or so and
he also surmises it's likely climate
change and more intense systems so it's
all of these things combining so it's
this compound effect it's not just one
thing it's a lot of things at once that
make it so bad right so you know it's um
I think one way to look at it is just
that hurricanes have been there for
eternity well before the Industrial
Revolution that's all part of nature
it's not like hurricanes they're our
presence or absence is due to climate
change it's the nature of the Hurricanes
are different and then of course people
are changing you know the urban the
coastal communities are expanding people
are building in places where they
shouldn't like Houston which there's
nowhere for the water to go so so much
of this is infrastructure related to
that completely yeah so that's actually
one of the biggest dangers is that
although a municipality may let you
build a beach home on a certain place
the bridge that connects you to that
coastal community or the water sources
that are coming to there the piping and
all that that's coming there those are
our break points our weak points weak
links that's what they say in Miami I I
had a condo in Miami I sold it someone
recently and of course what I was most
worried about wasn't so much the water
it was the anticipation of the water and
getting a mortgage or insurance but they
say before the water even becomes a
problem you know above the ground it's
already a problem but before it becomes
a problem where people can't live there
it could be an issue with
with septic tanks that could become an
issue before even clean drinking water
to saltwater intrusion those things may
come and push the people away before the
water itself is actually too much for
the people to handle that's right I mean
this isn't maybe an interesting point to
segue so at Columbia we have this
partnership that Columbia climate
science group has a partnership with the
Business School and so one of the things
we've been doing is bringing the most
advanced climate science to the business
community to the private sector and so
one of the results of these of this
partnership has been an investigation
into the impacts the economic impacts of
these coastal storms on the real estate
value of these coastal communities and
I'm sure you know this but one of the
interesting things for the Florida
market for the Miami market and for new
coastal New Jersey and the Hamptons is
that if you and I were fortunate enough
to have both five million dollar homes
right on the beach I know you know if we
had this you and I would be neighbors
we'd have equivalent value homes but
let's just say my home has more what we
call Fairweather flooding that is you
know the during a high king tide my
front lawn floods more than yours today
in today's market this was actually
analysis of the Zillow data set in
today's market my house will sell for a
5 to 15 percent discount relative to
your so the cost the economic cost of
climate change is actually in the market
now so you mean that means I can afford
that house that's yeah so I don't want
to spend too much more time in this
because we want to talk about solutions
oftentimes people are overwhelmed by all
this information and they can feel like
there's nothing they can do and you know
and I think there's some legitimacy to
the fact that ok so I stopped using a
plastic bottle that's not really
directly related to climate change but
shutting your light off is but it's such
a small thing so first let's talk about
personal responsibility cuz that's only
a small sliver of the whole pie because
there's corporate responsibility and
political responsibility so what can
people do what's the what are the most
effective things that you think they
could do to kind of bring about change
right so that I mean that the single
most effective thing that the average
American can do is we're do
their flight reduce their air time that
is a huge contributor to one's carbon
footprint and so if one is flying
extravagantly unnecessarily one should
dial that back and I want to be really
careful here because you and I aren't
here to tell people how to live their
lives you know that's not what this is
about it's just you know if one wants to
look at one's day-to-day life what can
one do and I think you know that's the
thing that I do I try to reduce my own
flying as much as I can I don't take
trips to the one places I used to travel
and I was earlier in my career so that's
you know one of the number one things
you can do but really the most important
thing we can do as a as a community is
to put a price on carbon really the
thing that's going to make a difference
is to support candidates that support
that action and what putting a price on
carbon so basically just putting a tax
on on the folks who or you know who are
making manufacturing the the fossil
fuels and then that kind of does bleed
down to consumers but the idea behind it
is theoretically that extra money goes
back in a check maybe it's a dividend of
some sort right back to the population
probably the the British Columbia
government has such a has such a program
and you know they wisely issued the
checks before the population voted on it
but it actually is a program so hugely
popular there and but the main point is
really to put a price on carbon so that
we realize that our we're basically
we're polluting the atmosphere although
we can't see carbon dioxide although we
can't smell it it's not like smog it's
not like ozone pollution it is really
warming up the planet and so to reduce
the dangers associated with that we have
to reduce emissions right we can do
things on a personal level but really to
get us as a community to buy into this
one of the things I was very surprised
by we had a conference at Columbia last
year brought in leading economists and
they said the one thing that all
economists agree on is we need a price
on carbon I've heard that and big
industry is behind it as well so the
bottom line is is is action in holding
our political representatives
honorable and and trying to get this
carbon tax pass also corporate entities
who produce a lot of carbon dioxide
letting them know that you know you have
a preference and your preferences for
companies to be cleaner and greener if
you will so these are ways that we can
influence beyond just shutting our
lights off but I do think shutting our
lights off kind of rubs off on our
parents maybe and our sisters and
brothers and friends and eventually you
get a Prius maybe the next-door neighbor
hears that you're saving a few hundred
dollars a month they get a Prius the
point is there's some of that grassroots
kind of changing society in our our
relationship with well I've got a real
life example I can tell you about which
is my own house so we put in a solar
panels in a backyard yeah we we produce
a hundred and fifty percent of our need
but more importantly is not my story but
as people drive by my house they'd see
this panel out in my backyard and I was
like how did you do that and I tell them
the you know it's not that complicated
and I showed them the economics of it
we're paid off after five years that's
great five of my neighbors put program
put them and these are farmers these are
people who are not you know these are
not all you know academics or climate
scientists these are just your average
people I'm on all sides of the political
spectrum that's like hey if I can save
money by penance and I saved money so I
think that's a great way to end it
Peter Domenico professor at Columbia
University which by the way I am at
Columbia University so this right here
is a guy who I run into fairly often
thanks so much for joining us and thank
you at home for joining us to learn more
about our climate coverage just visit
CBS news.com and click on the tab I on
Earth and I will see you again soon
right here on CBS News